[Musique]
à 19 ans je suis parti m'installer en
angleterre pour étudier la musique et la
production musicale et c'est là que j'ai
réellement commencé à découvrir et
comprendre la créativité un jour à
l'université le professeur nous a donné
un exercice plutôt intéressant il nous a
donné à tous un son très simple d'une
seconde
je vous le fais écouter ensuite et nous
a demandé de réaliser une composition
musicale entière la plus riche et la
plus intéressante possible en utilisant
uniquement
ce sont là alors ma réaction à l'époque
ça a été de me dire c'est impossible
comment ce que je vais bien pouvoir
composer quelque chose de beau de riches
d'intéressant avec seulement ce sont là
et puis parce que j'étais bien obligé je
me suis mis à poser des questions à
tester des choses à sortir de ma zone de
confort et j'ai fini par réussir à
réaliser cet exercice je vous montre
quelques exemples concrets de ce que
j'ai fait pour modifier le son d'abord
je les fais passer dans mon ampli de
guitare de la distorsion pour donner des
harmoniques jeu les réenregistrer avec
un micro et puis je les importer dans un
programme qui me permet de jouer comme
un piano bon je vous passe les détails
techniques j'ai fait quelques
modifications au son et je suis arrivé à
ce résultat 6
[Musique]
ensuite je suis parti du même son mais
je les fais passer dans une grande
reverb ce que ça fait en fait c'est ça
donnait l'impression en sont qu il est
entendu dans une immense cathédrale qui
résonne très fort puis j'ai coupé juste
la fin du son pour avoir la partie qui
résonne et j'en ai fait un instrument
[Musique]
dernier exemple je suis reparti du son
de départ mais je les pitchs et
plusieurs octaves plus bas pour avoir un
son très grave que j'ai après coupés
très courts pour qu'il soit percussif et
qui ressemble un peu au son d'une grosse
caisse de batterie vous avez compris le
principe
j'ai continué comme ça pendant un moment
j'ai trouvé une multitude d'idées
sonores différentes
et puis je les ai toutes rassemblées en
une composition finale voilà je vous
fait écouter un petit extrait du
résultat
[Musique]
m
à
mais bon
[Musique]
la créativité souvent vu comme quelque
chose d'un peu mystique comme une sorte
de don du ciel dont une petite minorité
de personnes auraient été gracié et les
autres pas qu'ici dans la salle se
considère comme quelqu'un de créatif et
pourtant cette capacité nous la
possédons absolument tous en nous et je
vais essayer vous en convaincre
aujourd'hui il ya trois étapes
fondamentales au processus créatif
la première c'est la connaissance la
connaissance plus j'en ai plus de
possibilités s'offrent à moi dès le
départ quand il s'agit de trouver des
idées originales ou des solutions à un
problème quelconque pour moi qui
composent enregistré produit de la
musique
si je connais plus de software si je
sais utiliser plus d'instruments de
musique cim à ma connaissance de la
théorie musicale et plus élargie
j'aurai plus de pistes de départ pour
être créatif dans mon domaine en
d'autres termes c'est un peu comme ma
boîte à outils et chaque fois que
j'apprends quelque chose de nouveau
c'est comme si je rajoute est un nouvel
outil dans ma boîte
la deuxième étape c'est la pensée
divergente la pensée divergente
elle peut se définir comme la capacité à
trouver une multitude de solutions
différentes pour un même problème ou une
multitude de réponses différentes pour
une même question dans le cadre mon
exercice au départ j'avais juste un son
et de la connaissance et avec seulement
ça il fallait que je trouve un maximum
d'idées différentes
la troisième étape c'est la pensée
convergentes et la pensée convergentes
elle elle peut se définir comme la
capacité à synthétiser tous les éléments
disponibles pour trouver la meilleure
solution
c'était bien beau d'avoir trouvé mille
idées sous leurs différentes encore
fallait-il que je sois capable de tout
les rassembler en une composition finale
je récapitule vite la connaissance mais
à ma disposition une série d'outils
la pensée divergente me permet de
trouver une multitude d'usagés
différents pour ses outils et enfin la
pensée convergentes me permet de
rassembler le tout en quelque chose de
cohérent ou dutil si j'ai pris l'exemple
de la création musicale pour illustrer
mon propos c'est bien c'est bien entendu
parce que c'est mon domaine de
prédilection mais je voudrais vraiment
insisté sur le fait que ce processus
créatif s'applique à absolument tous les
domaines pas seulement les domaines
artistiques dans des proportions
différentes bien entendu mais à tous les
domaines quand même si je prends
l'exemple d'un avocat est donc un
domaine qui n'est pas vu comme quelque
chose de forcément créatif mais au
départ l'avocat il a besoin il a besoin
d'énormément de connaissances il doit
connaître par exemple les textes de loi
l'histoire les précédents et doit il
doit être capable d'utiliser une série
d'outils technologiques institutionnels
et ainsi de suite
ensuite il doit être capable d'approcher
cette connaissance d'un maximum d'angles
différents pour proposer une série de
pistes d'idées de solution et finalement
il doit pouvoir rassembler tout ça pour
formuler une stratégie la plus cohérente
la plus efficace pour régler le problème
de son client on retrouve bien les trois
étapes
alors pourquoi est-ce qu autant d'entre
nous ont du mal à être créatifs bien mon
hypothèse c'est que notre modèle de
société repose très largement sur deux
des trois étapes de la créativité à
savoir la connaissance et la pensée
convergentes
si on regarde le système éducatif la
quasi totalité de notre cursus consiste
en un à prendre un sujet la connaissance
et deux prouver qu'on a bien appris ce
sujet en répondant à une série de
questions standardisés qui ne requiert
pas de créativité particulière la pensée
convergentes
on nous demande 5 + 5 égale combien
quelle est la capitale de tel pays ou
comment se décline tel verbe en latin
non seulement à quasi aucun moment la
pensée divergente n'est vraiment
valorisé au stimuler mais pire encore si
un élève décide de se montrer créatif et
d'interpréter un énoncé à sa manière ou
de faire quoi que ce soit d'autre que de
donner la réponse précise
attendu par le professeur il sera bien
souvent sanctionnés par des mauvais
points une réprimande ou pire encore par
des
des critiques de la part d'autres
camarades de classe du coup cet élève
créatifs à près de 3 fois il va avoir
compris la leçon il va mettre sa
créativité de côté se ranger et faire
comme tout le monde et cette hypothèse
ll est largement appuyée par une étude
qui a été menée dans les années 80 par
deux chercheurs américains et ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est qu'ils ont tenté de
mesurer la pensée divergente de 1600
enfants de 5 ans en leur faisant passer
un test simple il leur en donner à tous
un objet banal comme par exemple un
trombone et leur ont demandé ensuite de
trouver un maximum d'utilisation
possible pour cet objet en réalité les
possibilités sont infinies dans le cadre
du trombone par exemple on pourrait la
réponse la plus évidente ce serait de
dire on peut attacher des feuilles de
papier avec mais on pourrait aussi
imaginer le déplier aiguisait le bout et
en faire une aiguille ou un hameçon de
pêche où on pourrait en faire fondre les
verser dans un moule et en faire un
autre objet on pourrait même imaginer
faire de la musique avec mais entre nous
honnêtement qui serait assez bête pour
passer son temps à faire de la musique
avec un trombone
[Musique]
moi j'étais un peu obligé de le faire
même si c'est pas très utile à la
présentation
merci et de cette étude il en est
ressorti quelques chose de vraiment
surprenant à l'âge de 5 ans 98 % des
enfants atteignent le score maximum ce
qui veut dire qu'ils sont considérés
comme des génies de la pensée divergente
mais ce n'est pas tout cinq ans plus
tard ils ont refait passer le même test
au même enfant
ils ont trouvé cette fois que seulement
30% d'entre elles atteignaient encore ce
score là cinq ans plus tard 12% ce qui
est important de noter ici c'est surtout
le fait que cette capacité à être
créatifs nous la portons absolument tous
en nous puisque rappelez vous à l'âge de
5 ans 98% d'entre nous en sommes même
des experts vous tous présents ici dans
la salle où vous qui regardez cette
conférence sur internet posséder en vous
cette capacité de naissance ça c'est la
bonne nouvelle
seulement bien souvent cette cette
créativité elle a été bridée et mises de
côté et c'est vraiment dommage parce que
ce que j'observe c'est que c'est que
nous vivons dans un monde de plus en
plus complexe et instable et qui change
à une vitesse phénoménale des nouveaux
métiers apparaissent tous les jours et
requiert de nouvelles compétences qui
changent elles mêmes ont constamment des
nouveaux problèmes de société se pose
aussi tous les jours en termes
d'économie de politique d'écologie ou
autre et c'est ma conviction profonde
que nous devons absolument libérer cette
créativité que nous portons tous en nous
si nous voulons être capables de trouver
des solutions pour demain nous avons
besoin de citoyens super entraînés à la
pensée divergente qui vont sans cesse
remettre les choses en question
essayer des nouveaux systèmes innover
créer bousculer enfin si je vous ai
parlé du système éducatif tout à l'heure
c'est pas par hasard je pense vraiment
qu'il faut tout faire pour éviter de
brider cette créativité que les enfants
portent en eux que vous soyez
professeurs éducateurs ou parents essayé
d'encourager les enfants à se montrer
créatif et à prendre confiance en leur
créativité parce que pour moi s'il ya
vraiment une compétence
qui les aidera à s'en sortir dans la vie
à s'adapter aux situations changeantes
de la vie à s'épanouir et être heureux
c'est celle là merci
[Applaudissements]